listen to me I've got you I Won't Let Go
one of the most successful movies of all
time Titanic is back on the big screen
February 10th remastered and in 3D in
honor of the movie's 25th anniversary
and fans of the franchise kind of lost
their minds when the new trailer and
poster dropped but not that the museum
you may expect yeah the new poster shows
Kate and Leo in their iconic Embrace as
Rose and Jack but fans were not too
happy with one tweeting this poster is a
mess I cannot believe somebody actually
approved it look at Kate Winslet's hair
two different hairstyles on each side of
her head agreeing other users added this
is a specially insulting to a character
with the best hair ever but she was
getting a perm when the iceberg hit uh
side part next to the center part don't
do her like that
while the original poster featured the
same disheveled hairstyle it was more
subtle because of the focus on the ship
itself which led to more tweets like
this poster is appalling where's the
boat
[Music]